>>> CNN HAS LEARNED THE JUICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW SEEKING FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE'S
TESTIMONY INTS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IN FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTEMPTS TO
STAY IN POWER AFTER LOSING THE
2020 ELECTION.
PENCE'S TEAM HAS INDICATED HE IS
OPEN TO DISCUSSING A POSSIBLE
AGREEMENT WITH THE DOJ TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST SOME TESTIMONY.
JOINING US, CNN SENIOR LEGAL
AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT PAULA
REID.
HE REFUSED TO GIVE TESTIMONY TO
THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE.
APPEARS A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH, JIM, BECAUSE IT'S A
DIFFERENT ENTITY.
A REQUEST FROM THE ENCAMPMENT IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN A REQUEST
FROM THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
PENCE IS SO UNIQUE IN HIS
ABILITY TO PROVIDE INSIGHT AND
EVIDENCE ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES AROUND
THE ELECTION AND AROUND THE
INSURRECTION.
RECENTLY THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT HAS BECOME VERY PUBLIC
ABOUT WHAT HE SAW, WHAT HE
OBSERVED AND HOW HE FELT ABOUT
IT AS HE PROMOTES HIS NEW
MEMOIR.
PUBLICLY OVER THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS HE'S TALKED ABOUT HOW HE
BELIEVED A TWEET FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ATTACKING HIM WAS,
QUOTE, RECKLESS.
VERY CRITICAL OF HOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HANDLED THE
INSURRECTION.
IT WAS EXPECTED, ONCE HE WAS
THAT PUBLIC WITH ALL THOSE
COMMENTS, IT WAS FULLY EXPECTED
THAT PROSECUTORS WOULD HAVE
FOLLOWUP QUESTIONS FOR HIM.
AS YOU NOTED, HE DID REBUFF A
SIMILAR REQUEST FROM THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE, BUT SOME OF HIS
AIDES HAVE SPOKEN NOT ONLY WITH
LAWMAKERS BUT ALSO WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO IF HE WOULD LIKE TO
COOPERATE, REALLY THE ONLY THING
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY GET IN
THE WAY HERE IS IF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WANTED TO TRY TO
ASSERT PRIVILEGE.
THAT IS SOMETHING HE'S DONE WITH
OTHER WITNESSES, THOUGH HE HAS
BEEN LARGELY UNSUCCESSFUL.
IT HAS SUCCEEDED IN DELAYING.
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE TWO
INVESTIGATIONS THAT THE NEWLY
APPOINTED SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
OVERSEEING, ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS THEY WANT TO HEAR IS TO
TRY TO MOVE THESE THINGS ALONG
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> DELIBERATE STRATEGY IT SEEMS
FOR TRUMP'S TEAM.
PAUL RAH REID, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S DIG IN DEEPER WITH
PAUL CALLAN, FORMER NEW YORK
CITY PROSECUTOR.
PAUL, HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU,
JIM.
>> WHAT'S THE LIKELIHOOD HE
TESTIFIES HERE -- AS PAULA
NOTES, IT'S DIFFERENT, A
SUBPOENA FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS DIFFERENT FROM A
SUBPOENA FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
SO DO YOU BELIEVE HE DOES
EVENTUALLY GIVE SOME SORT OF
TESTIMONY?
>> YES, I THINK AT THE VERY
LEAST HE'S GOING TO COOPERATE
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND GIVE THEM AN
INFORMAL, IN-HOUSE INTERVIEW.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO WIND UP IN
FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY AS WELL.
THERE'S A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TESTIFYING AND
COOPERATING WITH THE DOJ AS
OPPOSED TO A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE.
REMEMBER PENCE HAS SAID THERE
WERE PROFOUND SEPARATION OF
POWERS PROBLEMS THAT WERE
PRESENTED INITIALLY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH WAS SEEKING
TESTIMONY FROM THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
BUT THE DOJ IS PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
SO THAT ARGUMENT DOESN'T EXIST
ANYMORE.
AND BECAUSE HE'S OPENLY ACCUSED
TRUMP OF HAVING RECKLESSLY
ENDANGERED NOT ONLY HIM BUT HIS
WIFE AND DAUGHTER WHO WERE
PRESENT ON CAPITOL HILL THAT
DAY, I THINK HE'S WAIVED THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ARGUMENT AS
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE COULD
PROTECT HIMSELF AGAINST A
LEGITIMATELY ISSUED SUBPOENA TO
TESTIFY IN THE CRIMINAL CASE.
>> OKAY.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE HE CAN PROTECT
HIMSELF.
AS PAULA NOTES, IT'S POSSIBLE
THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM CAN
ASSERT SOME SORT OF PRIVILEGE
CLAIM HERE.
LIKELY TO WIN ON THAT ARGUMENT?
>> I THINK THEY'RE LIKELY NOT TO
WIN BECAUSE PUBLICATION OF HIS
BOOK HAS REALLY LET THE HORSE
OUT OF THE -- WHEREVER IT'S
CONFINED IN WASHINGTON.
>> OUT OF THE BARN, EXACTLY.
>> OUT OF THE BARN.
I GUESS THERE ARE BARNS IN
WASHINGTON.
IN ANY EVENT, IT'S WAIVED I
THINK.
ALSO, TRUMP LAWYERS SHOULD HAVE
ASSERTED THAT EARLIER AGAINST
THE VICE PRESIDENT WITH RESPECT
TO PUBLICATION OF THE BOOK.
THEY DID NOT.
I THINK THERE'S A VERY GOOD
ARGUMENT HERE THAT THEY'VE
WAIVED THEIR RIGHT NOW TO ASSERT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ON THAT
ISSUE.
>> SUCH A GREAT POINT.
SO MANY BOOKS HAVE BEEN WRITTEN
BY FOLKS WHO REFUSE TO TESTIFY
BEFORE VARIOUS COMMITTEES HERE.
PENCE'S TEAM HAS SAID THEY'D BE
WILLING TO TESTIFY ON SOME
ISSUES.
IS PENCE'S TEAM SETTING SOME
GUARD RAILS AROUND THE SUBJECTS
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT AND WILL
NOT TALK ABOUT?
>> YES.
I THINK THEY ARE.
OBVIOUSLY THE DOJ WILL WANT HIS
COOPERATION.
I'M SURE THEY'LL BE WILLING TO
SIT DOWN AT LEAST INITIALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE LIMITATIONS.
THE REAL QUESTION IS, IF THEY
REALLY NEED HIS TESTIMONY TO
INDICT TRUMP, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, PENCE IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST VICTIMS OF TRUMP'S
ACTIONS ON JANUARY 6th.
HIS FAMILY WAS IN IN DANGER.
HE PERSONALLY WAS IN DANGER
BECAUSE THE CROWD WAS CALLING TO
HANG PENCE AND INTERFERE WITH
THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
SO HE'S A VERY IMPORTANT WITNESS
I THINK IN ANY CRIMINAL CASE
THAT COULD BE BROUGHT AGAINST
TRUMP.
>> AS AN EXPERIENCED PROSECUTOR,
WHAT IS YOUR GUT AS TO HOW FAR
ALONG THE DOJ INVESTIGATION IS
GIVEN THAT THEY ARE NOW SEEKING
THE TESTIMONY OF MIKE PENCE?
DOES THAT GIVE YOU AN INDICATOR
THAT THEY'RE IN THE FINAL
STAGES?
>> I THINK THEY ARE IN THE FINAL
STAGES.
OF COURSE, OUT OF LEFT FIELD WE
HAD A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
APPOINTED BY A.G. GARLAND.
I THINK THIS SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
IS GOING TO COME IN AND REALLY
ACCEPT THE INVESTIGATION WHICH
HAS OCCURRED TO DATE.
I HAVE NO DOUBT IT'S BEEN A VERY
THOROUGH AND ALMOST COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK UNLIKE THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WHICH, OF COURSE,
WENT ON FOR YEARS, I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THIS THING WRAP
RELATIVELY QUICKLY IN TERMS OF
THEM MAKING A DETERMINATION
ABOUT WHETHER TO INDICT A FORMER
PRESIDENT OR NOT.